[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video i want to further
discuss the rumors that have been
circulating over the last few months
regarding the possible creation
of a harry potter tv show initially the
rumors surrounding the possibility for a
harry potter tv show
were leaked by the hollywood reporter a
harry potter
live-action tv series is in early
development at hbo max
sources tell the hollywood reporter that
executives at the warner media banked
streamer
have engaged in multiple conversations
with potential writers
exploring various ideas that would bring
the beloved property to television
sources say broad ideas have been
discussed as part of the early stage
exploratory meetings news that talks are
underway for a harry potter tv series
should come as no surprise given the
value of the franchise to warner bros
rowling's seven book series was adapted
as eight feature films
that grossed more than seven billion
worldwide
but that was a few months ago and since
then fans have started to lose interest
primarily because warner media haven't
properly publicly address the rumors
themselves we only heard it second hand
in fact fans have been quite skeptical
of the rumors myself included
as a harry potter tv show sounds almost
too good to be true
however just this last thursday at an
investor conference
warner media ceo jason keller broke this
silence
and discussed the potential expansion of
the wizarding world
there's this little thing called harry
potter which is one of the most beloved
franchises and we're incredibly thankful
to be able to partner
with jk rowling and so i would argue
that there's a lot of fun and
potential there as well killar told the
morgan stanley technology
media and telecommunications conference
during a session that was webcast
what killer didn't do however is
elaborate on what exactly those plans
are
i think that with killer's statement and
the rumors leaked a little while ago
we should be able to paint some kind of
a picture here furthermore there are
additional rumors circulating
that warner bros have additional plans
for the cursed child
the stage play which premiered in 2016.
these rumors
suggest a new tentpole based on the play
which could either be a very good
or a very bad thing given the polarizing
nature
of the cursed child's story however as
far as i know
these rumors are entirely
unsubstantiated at this stage
rest assured between all of these rumors
we have to get
something and that's it for this video
if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel
you